-The Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study
is an amazingly exciting place.
It is intergenerational,
it is international,
and it is a place where
people come together
in every discipline
to work together
and to learn from each other.
-What the Radcliffe
Institute can do
is make sure that the
best minds of our society
have place and time
to do important work.
-When I applied for a
Radcliffe fellowship,
I had been a playwright
for 20 years.
I was needing to force myself
to be creative on an airplane
or in that moment before my
son woke up in the morning.
This has given me an
opportunity to just actually
breathe and be an artist
and be still and imagine.
-My project for
this year, I've been
writing a book called
Born Translated,
The Contemporary Novel in
the Age of World Literature.
-I'm pursuing a radical
alternative in which the Big
Bang is a big bounce.
-A book on medical tourism.
-Can we take what we've
learned from computer systems
and bring that into biology?
How does that help us
understand biology better?
-This is the young lady
with the nice smile
and the pleasing drawl
who came to us last year
from Mississippi.
Her Southern-ness as well as her
blackness made her stand out.
-My days are so filled with
anthropology and those things
that when was the
last time I ever went
to go hear something about
computer science or physics?
-As an undergraduate, I was
very appreciative to have
this opportunity to work
one on one with a professor.
It also gave me a perspective
on the academia life
that I never had before.
-I feel that you're missing
this great opportunity
to talk about some other
kind of revolutionary moment.
Often, in the
middle of a project,
you realize that you have sort
of accretions of old ideas
that you've never
quite thought through.
And so this was really
fantastic opportunity
to have people push at those
and push me in new directions.
-It's been a terrific year.
I had fairly ambitious
plans for what
I was trying to
accomplish this year,
and I think that, for the most
part, that I exceeded them.
-The Schlesinger Library
collects the raw materials
of women's lives across the
long course of American history
right up to today.
The women whose raw materials
we collect sometimes
know that they're
making history.
Most of the women
we collect would
be surprised to know
that people consider them
an important part of the story.
-Harvard undergraduates
and graduate students
use the collection.
There are outside
researchers, faculty
from other institutions,
independent scholars that
come and use the collection.
-I was working on the
Betty Friedan collection
in the manuscript department
right about the same time
that I was reading The
Feminine Mystique in class.
I really value getting to really
get up close to the history.
-We are working extra hard to
digitize as many collections
as we can.
By making it available
online, people can view it,
they can do research, they can
just scroll through photos,
they can use it in whatever
way that they need to use it.
-What made this
seminar unique was
that it was a real
mixture from people
who are basically
neuroscientists
as well as people
who are economists,
people who are public
policy types, and law types.
The hope was that that could
create some synergy and also
some future research
that would maybe
help the-- this is an ambitious
way to think about it--
but maybe help the country
and the world do a bit better
in the future.
-When Iran and
the US negotiate--
-We were trying to understand
if neuroscience, at the point
that it is now, whether
we have something
to say to policymakers.
-When these two
tribes come together--
-So I think we started
a communication.
I think that's probably
the most important goal.
-Should the government
just let him die?
-Just a few minutes
after the sessions,
people are already thinking
about collaborations
to do new work.
There's a kind of openness
on the part of the Radcliffe
Institute to
intellectual experiments
which maybe go off a beaten
path but which can in the end
have tremendous payoff.
-At the Radcliffe Institute,
not only are we committed
to the creation of new
knowledge and new ideas,
we are firmly committed
to sharing those ideas
with a larger public, both with
audiences here in Cambridge
and through live streaming
through the internet.
-If you come to the
Radcliffe Institute
you should be
coming to interact.
-New breakthroughs or
advances, actually,
often happen at the
boundaries between
traditional disciplines.
And Radcliffe is just
about the perfect setting
for that to happen.
-It has the opportunity
to be like a stone dropped
into a pool, where an action,
an experiment, a conference,
an initiative can then have
lasting influence, or not.
And so the kind of
experimentation and innovation
that's possible at Radcliffe
offers a great deal.